hey guys what's going on welcome to the
16th Python with tkinter in a actual
creation of a program tutorial video
series in this video what we're doing is
actually adding the functions that we're
calling in some of our menu items so
that's add top indicator middle
indicator and bottom indicator so let's
go ahead and get started so to start
we'll do add top man Skype patrol and
add top indicator and we'll just say
what and what is going to be like what
indicator are we adding and then we're
going to go ahead and global top
indicator and then we're also going to
global again that counter so if anybody
changes the indicator again we don't
want to wait maybe 30 seconds we want to
want to issue that a force update right
now so that's that now we're going to
kind of throw in some conditionals here
so for example if the data pace equals a
tick so if we're watching tick data
we're not going to be adding RSI or MACD
and all that there's no real reason for
that it's going to be really wild so
we're just going to throw a pop-up
message and we're gonna have this pop-up
message say indicators in tick data not
available easy enough subsequently if
what equals none if what equals none
we're just a top indicator equals what
basically so that will equal none again
so if that's the case I'll leave what
and then we're going to set that counter
to 9000 which will force an update and
we'll basically remove the indicator if
from the graph next we're going to say
if and actually we're gonna go ahead and
make that an elephant Lee that's a
problem that has been a problem since
the original program to update that and
get help anyway if Elif and then I guess
this could be really else actually let's
see now I really need to be knowledge so
if L if what equals
I sigh then we want it to be a relative
strength index so if that's the case
RSI we're going to call it's our side
cue for like basically like a question
so when the user chooses RSI it's not
really as simple as like okay I want RSI
done okay so an RSI has a question of
how many periods of time are we
considering here so generally an RSI is
a period of 14 so say you're you're
you're looking at a month month worth of
data when you are let's say you're
looking at nine months of data okay and
you apply an RSI relative strength index
generally it's going to be a 14 days
window per RSI calculation but some
people might want to do 22 or five or
whatever and so you want the user to be
able to change their minds so we're
going to be our s IQ for our site
question it's going to be a little
window here and so we TK TK very similar
to or pop up kind of idea that we were
using and then we're gonna say RSI q dot
WM title and this will be periods okay
so this is gonna be like a pop-up
message that are a pop-up window rather
it is like okay you've chosen RSI how
many periods do you want this art side
to be so RSI set the window title the
periods and then we're going to pose the
question to our user and that will be
basically we're going to make a label
equals ttk dot and capital l label and
then where is this going
it's going to the RSI Q and then the
text to our user will say um choose how
many periods you want each RSI
calculation to consider um and let's see
that'll do for now we'll keep that so
that's our label choose how many period
you want to each RSI calculation to
consider and then we'll do label dot
pack and again we'll say side equals top
because we're going to put a button
below it fill equals x and then pad Y
Patty equals 10 now we're going to go e
equals ttk let's fix this e equals ttk a
period entry so this is like an entry
widget for tkinter and then that's for
the RSI Q window and we're going to say
you could have it be blank but we
actually we're going to kind of we'd
like it to be there to be a default
values and soleko might not even know
like what would be a good number so they
might guess and throw in a really bad
number so we'll just insert and also
some people might choose to go the
default is typically 14 so some people
might just want the default so we're
going to go ahead and insert at the
zeroth place 14 just the number 14 will
be inserted and then we'll say e dot Pak
easy enough and then we're going to set
the focus focus set on the basically
what is filled in two into here so now
now we're going to do yeah define
callback and then we're going to global
top indicator and then global dat
counter as usual now we're going to use
a get operation here for so periods
periods a equals e get so it's going to
get what was put in to the focused a dot
insert basically which is an entry
widget so it's going to get whatever was
typed in there and then we're going to
say group equals an empty list for now
and now we're going to say group dot
append and to that we're and append RSI
because that's what the user chose and
then we're also going to do group dot
append periods
and then we're going to say the top
indicator equals group now so that's
going to be RSI comma 14 will be what is
stored under top indicator now we're
going to set that counter to 9,000 to
force an update and then we're going to
say we're going to go ahead and print to
console um set top indicator to an N
comma group like that and finally once
we've done that we don't need our window
anymore so we're just going to do RSI q
dot destroy so as soon as they basically
enter something it's going to run this
callback as you'll see in just a second
and then as soon as everything's done
it's just going to destroy the window so
actually hitting okay really
it's going to run callback but it's
really just destroying the window at the
end of the day when it's resetting a
value so now we're going to go ahead and
do B for button equals T TK capital B
for button where's that button going
it's going to RSI q what is the text on
that button it will be submit and then
the width of that button will be 10 and
the command that button commands
callback finally be dot pack and then
we'll go TK main loop empty parameters
and then um that's for RSI because RSI
has parameters that we're going to allow
the users set now we're going to say
MACD so this was L if RSI so now we need
a new Elif so that's if it's RSI now L
if what equals MACD :
let's global top indicator global dat
counter then we're just going to say
this one's a lot easier indicator top
indicate or equals MACD and then we're
going to say dat counter equals 9000 so
in this case this is much easier we
could allow them generally um it's like
24 12 and 9
I want to say or 22:12 men I can't I'm
not able to think of it right now but
it's like twelve and nine I think is the
second two values generally most people
use the default if MACD I've never
really heard anybody changes it but in
the future it would be kind of nice to
allow man it's driving me nuts oh no the
three values but anyways there's three
typical values but it would be nice to
let the user change them but as you can
say see it's kind of a pain that took us
to do it but eventually we will let the
user change them so that's it for change
you know basically add a top indicator
so so we let's go ahead and run this and
see if anything goes wrong because it
very well may invalid syntax somewhere
if data pace one equals that's a syntax
error that would be an assignment
operator we want to comparison operator
let's try again okay agree top indicator
RSI pops up default 14 periods mid and
then we say okay set top indicator to
our side 14 no problem awesome um and
then if it's what it says it sets it to
none and if it's MACD it sets it to MACD
no problem okay so where am I I'm over
here
let's go ahead and exit out of this come
over here to our shell like so this and
the middle indicator is going to take us
a little bit but let's go ahead and and
got enough time in this one I guess
we're up ten minutes at the moment but
that's okay we'll just copy this and
this is this is what really pains me to
do in the future we will fix this I
promise
hopefully this isn't bothering everyone
as much as it bothers me but copy that
entire function post and we're going to
come up here instead of add top
indicator add bottom indicator global
not top indicator global bottom
indicator that's that that and actually
let's go ahead is it
I can't member if I capitalized or lower
yeah I did lowercase it actually so copy
that come back down here to bottom
indicator that's bottom indicator there
so global bottom with the lowercase B I
capitalized it and then everywhere you
see
indicator bottom indicator this should
all be the same type indicator bottom
indicator top indicator nope bottom
indicator top indicator nope bottom
bottom okay
let's save and run that real quick and
see how we did
so bottom indicator RSI pops up fabulous
and oh we need to change the text but it
did
most likely set the bottom indicator but
let's see set top indicator to now set
bottom indicator to group okay save that
and we're good and now what we need to
do is we need to do the middle indicator
and I think I'll save that for the next
videos this one's a little bit longer
and it's not as simple as this was so
anyways again sorry for the copy and
paste of that function we'll we'll fix
that
feel free to some people say I should
give more challenges in the video so
challenge combine these two functions
and set it just should just be add you
know indicator and then really we should
we should combine all of the indicators
and then you know you've got what in the
comma where you know you should have
something like that so maybe we'll do
that in the future but till then
challenge so anyway um so that's at next
video we're going to add that middle
indicator so stay tuned for that if you
guys have any questions or comments
please feel free to leave them below
otherwise I was always thanks for
watching thanks for all the support and
subscriptions and until next time